now Ukraine says Russian forces have
launched new missile strikes on coastal
towns in the southern regions of Odessa
and mikalayev a cave has released
footage of what it says is the aftermath
of the attack which hit several
buildings along with Port infrastructure
on the Black Sea Coast Russia attacked
odessa's port at the weekend casting
doubt on Friday's breakthrough deal to
resume grain exports to the world
and Ukraine's military says it's used
Advanced U.S weapon systems to strike
more than 50 Russian military Targets in
recent weeks it credits the multiple
rocket launching trucks known as high
Mars with helping to destroy ammunition
Depots and bridges in russian-held
territory Ukraine has only a handful of
these vehicles with more on the way but
they've also become targets for Russian
attacks
this is high Mars a high Mobility
artillery rocket system the Crown Jewel
in Ukraine's growing arsenal of U.S made
weapons
and this is what it can do the high Mars
can pull up in the middle of a road and
fire off multiple Rockets very quickly
and their Precision guided so they can
accurately Target Russian Munitions
combat centers and more
high mass is basically a truck carrying
a pod containing six missiles it can be
reloaded in three to five minutes most
artillery is mounted on slower moving
treaded vehicles or towed by trucks but
a high mass can get away quickly once
it's fired off its payload or as the
military term goes it can shoot and
Scoot
its missiles have a range of 80
kilometers far more than most Russian
Artillery
this means the Russians must move their
sensitive targets like ammunition Depots
further from the front lines this makes
it harder to supply its combat units
analysts say this is the game-changing
part of high Mars Ukraine says its
Rockets have destroyed at least 30
Logistics hubs and ammunition Depots
Russia says it has destroyed at least
two of the high mass trucks Acclaim the
U.S denies but Ukraine's ability to use
them effectively will also mean hiding
these pressure systems well keeping them
supplied with ammunition is up to the
West
and see what sort of difference these
weapons are making with Mark Montgomery
uh he's a the senior director of the
center on Cyber and Technology
Innovation and the foundation for the
defense of democracies welcome to DW
what do you think have these high mass
changed the game or is it too soon to
tell
well thank you for having me and and I
do think the high Mars and the guided
missile larger rocket system or gimlers
Munitions that fly the 50 uh miles or 80
kilometers that they launch have made a
significant difference because what
they're allowing ukrainians to do is
hold Russian Logistics and command and
control at risk in a way that they
couldn't with the m177 howitzers with
traditional 155 millimeter rounds so
they have made a significant difference
they're affecting the Russians and
that's why the Russians are attempting
to Target them right and it's
interesting that that that
you've just said and we said in the
report this this concentration on the
stretching of Russian Logistics lines
because we saw at the start of this war
that that was a problem for Moscow
that's right when they were trying to
fight around Kiev they're on extended
lines and they failed so in this new
campaign they have fighting broadly uh
generally from Russia into the dambas
they they would appear to have shorter
Logistics and command and control lines
which are easier for them to control and
they can be more successful but what
with these Munitions those can even
those compact uh lines of communication
can be held at risk and and create
problems for the Russians so I really do
think this is uh well you know Game
Changer is a tough term this
significantly sways things in the
Ukrainian Advantage if they have enough
rounds and more of these high miles are
expected to be delivered is that right
that's right so we've just announced
four more of the uh High Mars vehicles
and there's equivalent Vehicles the
m270s coming from European countries so
they'll have upwards of you know two
dozen of these vehicles eventually but
again as I said a moment ago the key is
the Munitions we have only they're very
discreet about the amount of Munitions
that are being given here as opposed to
the 155 millimeter where we say we've
delivered 411 000 or something we we say
things like hundreds and so I am
concerned about this I want to make sure
that we're getting enough it's I think
it's critical that we get significant
gimlers Munitions into Ukraine for use
on the high Mars vehicles that
discretion's an interesting point
because again in the early months of
this this war that we were seeing a
government spokespeople uh taking to the
the media saying we're going to be uh
delivering this many of this sort of of
uh weapon and this many of this sort of
uh a weapon and one at the time you
couldn't help looking at that and
thinking well should you really be
telling the world what about your plans
so I think you know when they're in
Broad numbers like 59 million you know
uh rifle rounds or 411 000 artillery
rounds you're probably okay I mean
you're not creating a unique thing to
attack in the very small numbers like
say the Nay Sams uh the the National Air
to surface you know service their
missile systems or the Harpoon missiles
uh coming from Denmark and then
eventually from the United States
probably want to be very cautious about
the numbers you tell I think in the high
Mars because of successful we're
comfortable saying the numbers I think
the rounds issue has more to do with we
know that these are troubling to uh
President Putin and his you know
leadership group because you know they
could almost reach into Russia
and uh that's that's I hope a bridge the
ukrainians don't cross with this weapon
system take full advantage of it to
destroy the Russian occupiers in the Dom
boss
okay
um I'd like to read you a tweet from uh
lithuania's foreign minister Gabriela
Lance Burgess
um and he tweeted this a couple of days
ago he said the agreement to unblock
Odessa would have been impossible
without high Mars it's not very clear
that the war will end if we arm Ukraine
uh faster I wonder Montgomery did
Ukraine do you think Ukraine bombed
Russia back to the negotiating table
seems quite like like quite a a big
claim that
I
I you know I'm not sure you can you can
add that two and two together and get
five right I mean that's a that's a
tough that's a tough linkage what I
would say is
the high Mars
um the uh the gimlers rounds the the
counter battery fire Radars allow us to
hit the artillery uh the Harpoon
missiles all these things are leveling
the playing field for the ukrainians so
that their own resilience which is the
real backbone of this defense you know
can evidence itself to the Russian
leadership so I don't think any single
weapon system doesn't
um and and I'm not sure what the
mathematics were and President Putin's
head for opening Odessa and clearly that
mathematics reversed and he closed it
and opened it and closed it over the
last few days with his attacks uh
missile attacks on the Odessa Port uh so
I wouldn't give it I'm not 100 sure the
Lithuanian foreign minister uh you know
can be validated on that all right
that's all very clear thank you so much
for uh elucidating that and spending the
time with us Montgomery from the
foundation for the offense of democracy
thank you
thank you
DW's Matthias Berlinger joins us from
Kiev for more Matthias what's the
situation in the Odessa region after
those missile attacks
so Odessa has been hit several times in
the in the past few days Odessa and the
neighboring Khalif and it's a clear sign
that Russia has not given up on these
regions if you remember in February and
early March Russia was able to capture
some large parts of the South but they
were stopped to make alive on their
march on to Odessa and as fighting seems
to have been stalled in the East they
seem to renew their claims on these two
cities however it's doubtful that they
can really advance in that direction as
an Ukrainian counter offensive is going
on so this is the message they are
sending and of course it has to do with
the grain deal the the not this strike
but the strike that was just a few days
earlier hit a port in Odessa and this
one was aimed at critical infrastructure
so um definitely there is tension there
now and worries in the region that there
might be other more strike might be
following and and the strikes that could
mean that these grain shipments don't go
ahead
they could they could it's hard to say
Ukraine is still preparing for these
shipments um and is still determined to
reopen these three ports under this very
special agreement that will allow for
these grains grains to be shipped out by
Turkish vessels that were by
turkish-owned vessels that will have a
safe passage into Ukraine into these
Ukrainian ports the passage to being
guaranteed by the Russians who have sent
them to would not attack these vessels
and the ukrainians who would open a lane
through this through the sea a lane that
is without mines and the hope is of
course that Russia would not dare to
attack Turkish vessels but the the weak
point is of course the supply lines
behind the ports theoretically Russia
has excluded attacking ports in this
agreement but trust of course in
Russia's action is not very high so the
preparations are going on but whether it
will help or not we will know only after
and Matthias we've also heard again that
Russia is ready to hold talks with
Ukraine on ending the war according to
Russian foreign minister Sergey lavrov
how is that being seen in UK
well there are a few reactions to what
Mr lavrov says here in Ukraine just
because people do not take him seriously
anymore a few days ago just a few days
ago he has said that negotiations would
be impossible and are excluded now he's
saying that they might be possible but
he's blaming the West on them before he
has been blaming Ukraine on them so um
this messaging by Mr lavrov in here in
Ukraine it's seen as a messaging to the
West trying to find the weak spots of
the West maybe these people who still
dream about negotiations about an end to
a quick end to the war via diplomatic
path or will still write open letters or
editorials in the west but clearly
nobody gives anything about what Mr
lavrov says here in Ukraine yeah
ukrainians aren't willing to give up
their own country are they DW's Matthias
burlinger reporting for Keith for us
there thank you